came to this video play kill young home
and definitely of course Carlo de Moura
very frequent opponent went for the
asics Slav gets always playing this
stupid 57
let's try not to spend too much time
just develop develop normally and tell
burn it's all right still how do you how
do you get some play here it seems very
solid for black could try for you for
maybe maybe I can take and play you for
pressurizing f7 this could be it could
be an idea take a new form maybe like
sea de de for and you cannot take
because f7 made take with the porn I
mean it could be an idea
still we can probably just play Bishop
e7 if I go he thought he could take on
your five de 594 okay okay but if I have
some ambition in this game I need to
need to take with the poem okay what now
this is this is very interesting take
Andy for me is there something better I
could I mean what I'm thinking about of
course our sacrifices on 95
I take he might play Knight c5 the app
store that's not spent ages 95 95 I have
queen bee six so takes Bishop takes yeah
okay come on it's a normal never kind of
situation okay I'm threatening all f7
and how to defend 27 is so ugly not sure
you want to do that that problem you can
apply only seven maybe I bishop g6 IV
sexing yes I thought I would take a play
Quincy phone is something better i
progetti probably not Quincy for
attacking the night incidentally also
hitting hitting the rock in this way so
if you came so i go here maybe b6 what
what what about before before if i go
beef I ok ok ok but this it is so
covered
was it still Bishop e3 Bishop e3
before me can do 90 phone strange
before hmm doesn't seem to win strangely
enough
it really looks like there should be a
win but I don't see it I simply don't
see it
yep going to a forum take here
yeah this wasn't the best possible play
this is not just clear once in a while
cannot play media fries this ah this is
sick gasps simply didn't find the right
continuation it was certainly completely
winning for what I mean I would be very
surprised if there if there wasn't
wasn't the win check yeah I always have
problem with this guy I'm not quite sure
why I constantly a very often get
completely winning positions and don't
manage to put them away don't don't know
jack don't know why check yeah come on I
hate it like reason so let's look how
how wide should win this how it should
be I mean this is just so bad okay
that's not to get to check frustrated
about that so what wins Bishop e3 is if
I played and it does win esox is the
winnings okay hmm
yeah what ye six let's try to understand
that okay cannot take and I'm
threatening g4 and and be four yeah its
platform just just over ok this is still
good for white but already tricky and I
didn't see Bishop situ of course after
that it gets it gets already it's out of
control yeah like a speck is winning I
don't know as I don't know there's some
time that people you just play crap
against I don't know i mean what check
out of position do you want to get to
win it's probably even probably what can
play many moves here to win what about
this one also wins i probably you can
enter any moves lined up winning this is
not winning yeah okay but of course what
what like likes rather obvious mistake
is to take only five if you just play
this there's nothing nothing much
happening and after this you simply have
big problems this is also bad because
quite obviously this is the better move
winning and winning a temple and ok and
this yeah this is just waiting for white
flat out but you need to find the the
correct continuation which i didn't do
something else yeah but this is strong i
mean how many winning moves do you want
alright thanks for watching